The Daily Mail has uh this report the
satanic temple has set up a display of a
sparkling demonic Rams Head in the Iowa
State House as an expression of
religious freedom alongside more
traditional minoras and Christmas trees
the groups have uh the groups has has
erected an altar topped with candles a
large banner and a ram figure with skull
covered in mirrors a Red Cloak and a
wreath the temple reportedly went
through all the correct administrative
channels for the display and only had
their original request to use a real
goats skull denied so there was no
attempt um to turn them down or anything
like that or to fight over this they
were just given exactly what they wanted
um aside from putting you know the
carcass of an actual animal in the state
house but everything else they got
founder of the satanic temple Lucien
Graves told uh
KCCI we're going to really relish the
opportunity to be represented in a
public forum we don't have a church on
every street
corner this display will be up for 14
days and it's protected under the First
Amendment supposedly but not everyone is
pleased with it Iowa resident Shelley
Flockhart is extremely concerned
organized a group prayer near near the
display on
Wednesday she told KCCI I hope that
people realize spiritual warfare is real
that there are evil satanic forces that
are trying to infiltrate our state she
said Christians must spiritually fight
against it and added it's a very dark
evil force and I truly hope uh people
know how to battle that
so um that's what's happening in Iowa
Iowa's govern govern Kim Reynolds is uh
not happy about this and she's spoken
out about it let's watch Governor Kim
Reynolds is denouncing a satanic holiday
display at the State House the Iowa
atheist and freethinkers group and the
satanic temple set up the display it
says that all religions should be
represented in a public forum but renold
said in a statement this morning she
finds this display objectionable she
says the best way to respond is to pray
over the capital and to recognize the
nativity scene on a display there
instead now I think there are other ways
to respond we'll get to that in a second
yesterday um in sort of an interesting
detail here during a town hall Ronda
santis was asked about this and um he
said that that some of this traces back
to the Trump Administration let's listen
so it's interesting I I I heard this and
then I was like well how did it get
there is that even a religion and lo and
behold the Trump
Administration gave them approval to be
under the IRS as a religion so that gave
them the legal ability to potentially do
it so I don't know what the legislature
what they how they analyzed it but it
very well may be because of that ruling
under Donald Trump that they may have
had a legal leg to stand up my view
would be that's that's not a religion
that the founding fathers were trying to
create um but I do think that IRS ruling
uh I was really surprised to see that
they did that
okay obviously this is a disgrace uh
just I mean obviously it should not be
allowed you simply don't allow Satanist
to set up a satanic altar inside your
state capital um building I mean that
that's the kind of thing that shouldn't
need to be
said and I don't give a damn what
argument you make I don't care about
whatever right you're trying to
supposedly
claim oh but we have a right to I don't
care if you think that
like that should be the
response when they go through the
administrative channels and say we would
we have a right to do this okay what you
think you're right sorry it's not
happening you just don't do it and let
him take you to
court take it all the way to to the
Supreme Court but you don't just do it
you don't just do it without putting up
a fight and that's what happened here
there was no fight the only fight was
okay you can't put an actual goat skull
but everything else is fine
now uh consider a few things here a few
points in no particular order first it
should it should go without saying what
what Ronda Sanders said there is correct
obviously the founding fathers would
have never tolerated this they obviously
never intended to give satanists the
right to set up satanic temples inside
government buildings and anyone who
tells you otherwise is a or a liar
or or both probably both Not only would
they not have tolerated this but they
would have arrested anyone who even
attempted to do something like
this okay so they were not the Live and
Let Live hippies that they're made out
to be for the most
part second Satanism is not a valid
religion in the theological sense of the
term okay it's an
anti-religion I mean it's designed to be
the opposite of a
religion and for most of these
self-professed satanists it's meant to
be nothing more than a troll of
religion like they don't even consider
themselves to be worshiping Satan really
and they'll be the first to tell you
that they are worshiping Satan even
though they don't uh consciously think
they
are but they'll be the first to tell you
that it's not that that's not what
they're actually doing they don't
think um it is a it is a mockery of
religion
the whole thing all of it is set up to
be not just of religion by the way but
of Christianity
specifically the whole thing is set up
to be the kind of the inverse of chrisan
it is a parody um a mockery of
Christianity okay so Satanism is not
like some other world religion it's not
like Hinduism or something Satanism is a
mockery of Christianity specifically it
is not a valid uh religion unto
itself
and and third it's interesting that
atheists are behind this um you know a
atheist groups are the ones who have
have push this and atheists are on
extremely Shaky Ground here really
non-existent ground because they're
claiming that satanists have the right
to set up uh you know the the satanic
altar in the
capital
but I mean what is a right where do
rights come
from I'm always harping on this point
because important point that it's a
question that's never answered in these
conversations
but if somebody is saying I have the
right to do
that says who what do you mean you have
the right to do it who says you have the
right to do that what do you mean you
have the right to do
it and and what if the government just
what what if Iowa had just said no you
can't you don't have that right we don't
recognize it Pure Talk has you covered
for the holidays with a free Moto g5g
phone no gimmicks no trading necessary
just sign up for Pure talks unlimited
talk unlimited text and 15 gig data uh
you can get all this for $35 and you get
the Moto G 5G phone for free but here's
the deal you need to move fast because
these phones are almost gone so if your
current phone is on life support upgrade
for free with pure talk the new Moto g5g
phone boasts a two-day battery life an
exceptional quad pixel camera and a
whole lot more Pure Talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
a half the price so make the switch
today it's an easy choice to make just
go to Pur talk.com wals to get this
exclusive offer and select the plan
that's right for your family remember P
talk gives you America's most Dependable
5G Network at half the price so make the
switch today that's pure talk.com Walsh
to claim your free Moto g5g phone with a
qualifying plan Pure Talk simply smarter
Wireless of course the October 15th tax
deadline has long since come and gone I
know many of you might be dreading the
stress of filing your taxes filing your
taxes can be a long excruciating process
to say the least but if you fail to file
you'll start to pile penalties on yourx
tax debt and that's why you need to
check out tax Network USA the team at
tax Network USA is a track record of
success they've reduced tax debt for
numerous clients totaling over a billion
dollars whether you're looking at a
$10,000 or a $1 million tax debt they
can help you with a settlement doesn't
matter if you haven't filed in one year
five years even a Whole Decade tax
Network USA is equipped to secure the
best settlement for you the expert
attorneys and tax professionals of tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no matter how they started don't
let tax debt control your life any
longer take the first step towards
resolving your tax issues by visiting
tax Network
usa.com Walsh that's tax Network
usa.com Walsh today there are only two
possibilities
either rights are things that are
invented arbitrarily by people you know
or they are as the founders believed
endowed by a higher power by the Creator
by
God it's one or the
other so but but if rights are endowed
by God then we have to ask whether God
endowed us also with the right to
practice Satanism in government
buildings does anybody want to step up
and say we have a god-given endowed
right to practice
Satanism you know inside the state
capital that's going to be a very
difficult case to make but that of
course is not even the case that
atheists would make they can't talk talk
about god-given
rights so they would say that rights are
human inventions that they're arbitrary
human constructs they don't have any
real reality they're just ideas that we
came up
with there's no fundamental innate
reality of a human right it's it's just
it's it's a concept it's a system that
we have
invented well if that's the case then
you wouldn't be able to complain if Iowa
had simply said no you don't have the
right to set that up
here because if government decides your
rights and and then if the government
says you don't have that particular
right
it's incoherent to insist that you do
because insisting that you do is to
appeal to a power higher than the
government but on the atheist view there
is no power higher than the government
they're the ones who decide this and so
if they say if they say you don't have
that right then you don't it's it it
doesn't
exist so then your argument would
be you know then if the government is
saying you don't have a certain right
it's totally incoherent for you to say
oh but I really do have that right and
you should recognize it
instead what you would be saying is I
should have that right you'd be saying
you're right I don't have that right
because rights are arbitrary human
constructs invented by the government on
my worldview because I'm an atheist uh
because their rights can't be anything
but that um so I don't have that right
but but but I should you know that
that's a right that we should invent for
me but that's not what the satanists and
the atheists are arguing and that
because they recognize that that's a
pretty that's a much weaker argument
when you say yeah I don't have a but I
should because then everyone could say
no you shouldn't I mean or maybe you
think you should but we don't
care and finally to return to a theme
from yesterday and uh really from every
other day on the
show you know as conservatives we do
not have to
tolerate everything okay it may come as
a
shock uh but we don't have to tolerate
every in fact we
shouldn't in fact our whole thing
is supposed to be that we
don't because we're in the business of
conserving conserving what the right to
practice
Satanism the right to turn State houses
into satanic temples is that what we're
trying to
conserve no we're conserving god-given
rights we're conserving truth sanity
Common Sense
tradition and this flies in the face of
all of
that you know which is why we should say
no and we can say
no yeah conservatives have to get
finally past this juvenile like
adolescent libertarian
thing this Live and Let Live Well we
can't tell people what to do you know
just do you do your thing and I do my
thing let's not bother each we'll stay
out of each other's way we got to get
past that
that
childish half-baked way of viewing the
world we got to get over
it
um and that means that in situations
like
this you can do what you know is the
right thing like anyone who looks at a
satanic temple being set up um in a you
know in a state like anyone look looks
at that and it's like that that doesn't
seem right okay that just doesn't seem
that does not
seem it doesn't seem like that should be
happening that's that's common that's
just a basic moral intuition we all know
that that shouldn't be
happening but conservatives for so long
have convinced themselves that they have
to defy their own moral
intuition for the sake of uh of Liberty
or
whatever but but that but that is based
on a very mistaken uh very as I said
juvenile sort of childish idea of what
Liberty
is and the juvenile childish idea of
Liberty is that Liberty means you
everyone can just do what they
want which which is which is
uh you which is like what your
teenager might think freedom
is some of the founding fathers thought
the freedom
is if You' like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed